高評価、チャンネル登録お願いします。
眠い
平成生まれっというと
まもなく爺（じじい）婆（ばばあ）と、言われます
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
というわけですね、
平成最初の動画でございます
令和に入って初めて撮る動画です
皆さん、令和自体もはじめしゃちょーをよろしくお願いします！
と、言いたいところではあるんですけども
平成もですね、あの、皆さんに
本当大変にお世話になりました
平成もありがとうございました(人''▽｀)
ありがとうございました
令和一発目何をしたいかといいますと
ちょっと、まだ、やっぱね、この
平成の気持ちが抜け切れてない
というか
こう
平成のねぇ、なんか
平成
・・・
へいせ～い！！
Kanon(カモン)
へいせ～い【はじめーん】
OK Kamon Kamon(オッケーカモンカモン)
へいせ～い！！！
・・・
あの、平成がまだ抜け切れてないという
ところがありまして、
なんかあの僕最近ですね、
グミ食ってるだけの動画が
１億回　(*_*)
再生
いったりして
けっこうあの
平成のYoutubeかいに
あの、自分で言うのもなんですけど
結構歴史を残してると思ってるんですよ自分で
なんでたぶん
グミ食うだけで
1億回再生行く人　あの
YouTuberでそういない
と思うんで
自分でちょちょちょちょちょ恥ずかしいんですけども
まあ
平成が産んだ
╲天才╱(^_-)-☆
かもしれない
みたいなとこありまして・・・
僕が平成の時に作ったYoutubeの動画を
ちょっと
見返してみようかなと思いまして
良くも悪くもですよ
編集の仕方とか
いろいろ変って来てて
当初の動画が今の僕に
どう映ってるか
どうしてそんなに再生回数が行ったか
とかがわかったりするかもしれないし
あ～なつかしいな～って
平成の振り返りにもなると思うんでちょっと平成の
歴史的な僕の動画を、あの
ぼくも一緒に見ていこうと思います
というわけで今日の動画は、
はじめしゃちょーの平成の動画を
一緒に見返していこう
のコーナーです
数は、少なくなりますが
はじめしゃちょーが投稿した平成の・・・
一緒に見ていきましょう
では、どうぞ
はい、というわけで一緒に見ていきましょう
え～最初の動画ですね
世界最大級のグミを一人で食う
という動画です
もう、タイトルの通りなんですけど
これが
あの、僕のチャンネルで平成で
一番再生されてる動画です。
もうね、１億回再生超えててほんとすごいんですよ。
ま、なんですごいかはわからないんですけどね
そういうのが何かわかればいいなと思って
あらためて私が残した平成の名作見ていきましょう
では、お願いします
動画：ふぅおっす
は）お～元気がいいですね。若い！！
動）わぁ”ぁ”ぁ”
は）はい
は）ま、続に言う開封の儀とゆうやつですね。
動）わぁ
箱）痛い
動）開けます！！
は）げんきですね！
動）ひぃぃ
は）若いね
動）はい、2つ！！あぁぁ　世界最大級のグミ
は）26になって開封の儀そうとう疲れるからね
動）うゎ
は）うゎでかい
動）ちょっと待ってｗ
動）うわーー
動）袋から開けます
動）うわぁ～ちょっとまって本当にグロイ
は）ちょっとまっていいかな
は）日焼けしてんね～
は）日焼けもしてるし直接机にグミをたたきつけてるんだね。
は）ばかな子だよ
動）うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
動）世界最大級の巨大グミ
は）でっか
は）よく買ったよこれほんとに
動）もぉ
は）ｗｗ
は）音が
動）こっちは保存しよう２個は無理だこっちは冷蔵庫に入れとこう
は）待って待って
動）こちらの・・・
は）最初から一個にしとけよ
動）世界最大級のブァームグミを一人で食います。
動）4000キロカロリーぐらいかな
そうゆう話もあるんですけど
はじめ：絶対食えないんだよな～
は）いきおいだと思ってたんでしょうね当時から
動画：この巨大グミ今から食います。
いただきます
はじめ：すごい勢いしかない
4000キロカロリーは食えんからね
うわぁ
はいっ
動画：はいっ、味はね、
はじめ：これマジきつかった
動画：ちょっと濃いかな～甘いです
動）甘い・・・
動）なんか・・
動）エロいね
動）これ、丸ごとごくってのめれば全部・・・
は）ここからなんかエロイね始まってる気がするんだよな～
動）おぇぇ
は）ブフｗｗ
は）すごいなんてな巨大な蛇食ってるだけだけど
自分で言うのあれですけど面白いですねー
動）ぅうぇ
動）落ち着け
動）まだいける
は）いやぁ、すげえ気持ち悪かった覚えはありますね
動）うわぁあぶねえこれやばいわ。思ってたのと違う
動）グミと思たんですけど、これグミじゃないよ
は）いや、グミだわ
動）おもってたのと違う
動）頑張れ
は）無理してんな俺当時からほんとに
動）いけるハイウェイ
動）う！
細かくなってる
はいはいなるほど編集の仕方が変わったなぁってめっちゃもうねぇ
全然テキストもなかったけど
意外と見れたなってことは
テキストいらないってことぉ？
動画のテキストいるかどうかちょっとわかんないです
今なんか程よく入れてるんですけど
あとおちもなんかてきとうでしたね
まだまだ若いころでした
次の動画なんですけども
コーラ風呂に体中メントスで入ってみた
ｗなるほど見てみますか
こぉっれ
俺逆にね
なんで炎上しなかったんだろうと
思ってるとかあるんですよね
これ、なんか正直ニベア黒いるタチ悪いなと思ってて
動）はい、もうOKです。みんなの言いたいことはわかります。どうせまた来るんでしょ
は）飲み物でお風呂作るんですよ
動）お金持ちですね、金の無駄遣い、粗末にすんな
動）そんなこと俺が一番わかってるよ！！
は）ちょっと待ってね★
この頃からなんか
えっｗｗ
炎上気にしてたんですよねつぎ行きましょ
動）メントスが何個だ？
動）72個おいてあるんですけど
は）バカァ～
動）今日は、なんとですね、
コーラ120リットルを使って
お風呂にコーラ風呂を作って、
そこに、
動）メントス、メントスを体中に
は）なんかテキストが小さいぞめっちゃ小さい
（動）付けて、（は）本日の実験
動）そのままコーラ風呂に入ります。
えぇっ、もったいないって？
バカヤロウ
男だぞ男！！
人生一度きりだぜ(・∀・)
夢かなえようぜ(・∀・)
は）はっはっはっはっはっは
やった理由が「男だったから」でしたね。
うわぁ暇やなー
今多分できんだよね時間がなくてそのこの頃はねi一日中動画に時間を下げてたからね
めっちゃ時間かけ動画とってました
メントス全部体に纏⁽まと⁾うとき
はいっ
動）つけるのに時間かかってたらもったいないんで
うん
動）この透明なセロハンテープで
動）メントス一個一個を、こう
は）はいっ
は）セロハンテープは透明なのしかな～～い
は）お～天才天才
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
この感じでね風呂に飛び込むと思います
いろいろといろいろやばいんで
は）ｗｗ
爆発するときは～
いくぞ
バシャン
シューー
えぇっ？
どれー　ねえ　ちょっと
動）ちょっと～
は）お～～
は）ハッハッハッハ
ハッハッハッハッハ
シューーーーーー
ブフッｗｗ
終わり方が雑やな～
落ちが見つかんなかったんでしょうね
当然そんな中何かやりやぁいいやみたいなところだったんで今の俺だったら許せないかもしれないね
とゆう感じのががありましたね
次はちょっと
ユーチューバー版 PPAP ペンパイナーポーアッポーペンですね
これ、懐かしい～
ちょっと見てみようと思います
懐かしいこれ平成つったらこれだったみたいのあったかねぇ
PPAP
きっつ、みるのきつ
アイハッバッペェェェーン
アイハヴァアッポ―
あぉ゛う?
アポォォペェン
アイハッバッペ⤴ン
アイハヴパイナッポー
あ゛⤴⤴ぅ!!
パイナッポッペーン
アッポッペ～～ン
ピュｩｩｩ(効果音)
パイナッポッペーン
ゔあ゛ぁ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛↑ぅ゛!!!
ペンパイナッポッアッポッペェン
は）ｗｗ
は）勢いｗｗ
ゔあ゛ぁ゛↑ぅ゛!!!の勢いがすごいな～～
ペンペンペンペン
ペンペンペンペンペンペンペンペン
ペペペペペペペペペペペペペペペペ
アッポーパイ!!!
アッポーペン ×1
アッポーペン ×2
アッポーペン ×3
アッポーペン ×4
アッポーペン ×5
アッポーペン ×6
アッポーパイ(真顔)
パ～イナッポ～ ×1
パ～イナッポ～ ×2
は）ぎづぅ“ぅ”ぅ”～
パ～イナッポ～ ×3
パ～イナッポ～ ×4
は）やだぁぁぁ
パ～イナッポ～ ×5
パ～イナッポ～ ×6
ペン ペン
麺⁽めん⁾
アッポーペン ×7
アッポーペン ×8
パイナッポーペン
パイナッポペン
麺!! ×1
麺!! ×2
麺!! ×3
パイナポー ×1
パイナポー ×2
パイナポー ×3
アッポーペン ×9
アッポーペン ×10
は）やばいやばいキモイキモイ
アッポーパイ ×1
アッポーパイ ×2
あ゛ぉう
ヒカキン
は）あっはっははっはっは
は）はぁっアッハッハ( ´艸｀)
YouTube～につなげやがったな。
ヒカキン!!!
アッポーぺ～ン
パイナポーペーン
お゛⤴ぉ⤵!
ペンパイナ～ッポーアッポッペン
アッポーぺ～ン
パイナポーペ～ン
お゛⤴ぉ⤵!
ペンパイナッポーアッポッペン
パイナポーペ～ン
アッポーペ～ン
ペンパイナッポーアッポッペン
おう!
ヒカキン
は）まじであの俺何でこれしようと思ったんだろうな
パイナポーぺーン　アッポーぺーン
おおーう!
HIKAKIN
ヒカキン
YEAH!!
はいっとゆうわけでいかがだったでしょうか
もう、なん何だろうね最後のやつは面白かったってかもうなんか見ててきもちわるっと思ったんですけど
あのなんか特に平成が終わるからって何か変わるわけじゃないんですけども
あの、こう時代が変わる節目を見られたということで
あの～令和もう引き続き
あの、はじめしゃちょーまぁ頑張るってほどじゃないっすけど
僕が楽しいと思える動画、
そしてそれを何か見てもらってまあ、
つまらないと思われてもいいし
面白かあったら面白いと言ってくれてもいいし
まあみんなで楽しめればいいなと思っております
とゆうわけで
令和もはじめしゃちょーをよろしくお願いマッスル
こういうのがダメなんだよな
FIN
ご視聴ありがとうございました。また見てね。
(｀・ω・´)
チャンネル登録＆高評価よろしくお願いします。